welcome the bar's in the back and
they're coming around with food i use
the most wonderful catering company
they only hire ex-convicts to give them
a second chance oh that's wonderful
get in here and meet everyone oh
lieutenants i want to introduce you to
my old neighbor john he's the head of
admissions at the calder academy in the
bronx
calder that's the best elementary school
in the city then my trial team gets
hired to work real cases
in a shuck my friend from major crimes
is here you're gonna love them maybe i
will maybe i won't well uh come on let's
go
let me take your coat no i need oh this
way what grade are your daughters in
they're in sixth grade oh wait i'm sorry
that's their reading level they're in
second wow
they sound quite impressive oh good the
food i'm starving
hello detective jeffords do i know you
ronald palmer
you arrested me 10 years ago you
testified at my trial
oh hey what have you been up to
prison yeah i shouldn't ask i spent 10
long years thinking about what i would
do
if i ever saw you again lettuce cup
ah oh
do you think i'm trying to poison you am
i always gonna be a criminal in your
eyes even though i've served my time no
no no i'm just not hungry right now oh
you said you were starving yes john
thanks for reminding me john
calder we're not just looking for good
students we want compassionate members
of the community
great terry has a passion for compassion
turkey pinwheel oh you're back again you
seem to be working this one spot a lot
well we're old friends remember i'll ask
again
turkey pinwheel why is there just one i
made it special
for you how is it special there's a
little something extra in it
wait are you still suspicious of me you
don't think i deserve a second chance
impossible lieutenant jeffords has a
passion for compassion
yeah you're right you know what i will
take this pinwheel
mmm delicious
[Music]
terry terry terry
are you okay i'm fine but that dog came
right at me and i have no idea why
it looked like you had a lot of food in
your pockets what
no that's not true this jacket never had
any pockets this is the style
oh my god you did think i was poisoning
you i mean you were the one who said he
spent every day in prison dreaming of
the day we'd meet again
so i can prove to you unchained you said
you put something extra in my food
love you said it's so creepy look tone
is everything man
i've been talking to a cinderblock wall
for the last 10 years
i'm sorry if my social skills leave
something to be desired
that is a really good explanation
you